it's time for this day in history
because nature is but art unknown today
and chance direction which thou canst
not see on our hundredth episode on this
day in history in 1911 Ronald Reagan was
born and on this very same day in 1985
Ronald Reagan announced his foreign
policy program the Reagan doctrine which
has been badly misunderstood by his
political descendants so Ronald Reagan
was a born born a good American boy he
he grew up and became a star of film and
television he I'm sorry I've lost my
place he was oh yes he was called a
dunce by the left and self-appointed
elite conservatives alike he entered the
Oval Office in an advanced age he was
divorced and remarried he fought
cultural battles from the White House he
frequently added provocative lines to
his speeches that drove his advisors
crazy he effected tax cuts and
deregulation at home and strength abroad
and he restored America's leadership in
the world after a disastrous Democrat
administration yeah that's where I was
that's what I that's why I couldn't find
that sounds kind of familiar doesn't it
that must be deja vu I don't know on
this day in 1985 on his birthday Reagan
articulated the foreign policy strategy
that would come to be known as the
Reagan doctrine he explained quote
freedom is not the sole prerogative of a
chosen few it is a universal right of
all God's children he went on we must
stand by our Democratic allies and we
must not break faith with those who are
risking their lives on every continent
from Afghanistan to Nicaragua to defy
soviet supported aggression and secure
rights which have been ours from birth
support for freedom fighters is
self-defense these lines have regularly
been ridiculed in the wake of September
11th as we now fight groups of radical
Muslims who appear similar to some of
the freedom fighters we once supported
even though really at that point isn't
even true there's this left-wing
suggestion that we funded Osama bin
Laden in the 1980s that's patently false
but Reagan's words are entirely true
unfortunately they're usually quoted out
of context the freedom fighters risked
their lives to defy soviet supported
aggression to defy communism our mortal
enemy the the Reagan doctrine does not
exist in the ether
floating above reality above time and
space the Reagan doctrine guided the
country to its victory in the Cold War
we won the Cold War
Ronald Reagan won the Cold War and now
we're here and we can long for the days
of Ronald Reagan the Gipper was a great
man and the 1980s were a great time in
many ways it was more sophisticated and
it was more polite and was more
civilized but now we're in a different
time with different priorities and
different challenges and different
political leaders applying strategies
outside of their time and context can
prove disastrous as we've seen in
several interventions longing for the
good old days is the sign of a decadent
culture a healthy culture moves forward
Ronald Reagan didn't try to solve the
problems of Chester Arthur or Grover
Cleveland so - we should honor the
Reagan legacy by living in our own time
and space and applying his guiding
principles along with timeless
philosophy and enduring tradition to the
challenges we face today to quote two
great men that's the only way that we'll
ever make America great again